bonsoir à vous jean louis bourlanges
bonsoir en france ce journaliste tué
celui de bfm tv ce cameraman de 32 ans
frédéric leclerc imhoff dans la région
de louhans ce est ce qu'elle est c'est à
dire que l'armée russe n'est pas une
désormais plus personne je crois qu'il
faut il faudra qu'une enquête ait lieu
ça montre simplement que les
journalistes prennent des risques pour
nous informer et mérite vraiment d'être
salués pour leur courage ce garçon en 32
ans qui couvrait une opération
humanitaire c'est là où on doit
s'interroger sur le comportement des
forces russes car c'était une opération
humanitaire ce n'était pas une opération
de combat dans laquelle il a pris 7
cet éclat d'obus mortels ça prouve une
violence absolument considérable je
crois qu'il faut le l'état français
demande le gouvernement demande une
enquête administrative précise complète
il faut éclairer les conditions nous
croyez qu'elle a des chances d'aboutir
cette enquête ne sais pas en tout cas
les les les ukrainiens les sucres et
gnafron j'en suis sûr tout ce qu'il faut
pour éclairer les conditions de ceux de
ce drame terrible je crois moi je
vraiment permettez moi de dire que de
rendre hommage à ce jeune ce jeune
journaliste deuxième mission d'après ce
que j'ai compris deuxième mission en
ukraine et qui paye de sa vie le risque
qu'il prend pour nous informer jean
louis bourlanges au vu des exactions de
l'armée russe de l'armée de poutine est
il encore admissible de discuter avec
lui comme l'a encore fait récemment
emmanuel macron et olaf scholz je crois
qu'il ne s'agit pas on peut discuter de
l'opportunité de ceux de ce genre de
discussions mais de toute manière nous
savons bien les uns les autres que nous
n'avons pas les moyens de remplacer
monsieur poutine à la tête de la russie
et nous savons bien aussi qu' il faudra
tôt ou tard et ce sera hélas sans doute
très tard car cette guerre est parti
pour durer avec toutes les conséquences
épouvantables qui s'y attachent
il faudra tôt ou tard qu'elle négocier
avec les russes donc le il ne faut pas
se tromper nuremberg cela n'a été
possible que parce que d'abord on avait
liquidé iter on avait occupé l'ensemble
de l'allemagne et que le führer était
mort et là on n'est pas dans ce cas de
figure on est dans un cas de figure très
épouvantable car je crois que les
exactions les violences
l'acharnement contre les civils les
massacres systématiques de l'armée russe
ne doive de doivent vraiment être
répertorié recensé qu'on doit
effectivement accumulé les preuves pour
un éventuel à un éventuel procès contre
ses dirigeants et contre les fauteurs de
guerre mais il faut savoir que tant que
les russes tant que poutine sera
enrichie à la tête de l'état c'est de
lui que dépendra la paix et ce n'est pas
encourageant car nous voyons bien qu'il
est totalement déterminée actuellement à
ne faire aucun mouvement en direction de
l'ap et la france discutent avec poutine
et en même temps augmente sans appuyer
son soutien militaire à l'ukraine c'est
ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron vous avez
les turcs qui discute également avec la
russie pour faciliter l'exportation
notamment des céréales et en même temps
livre des drones à l'ukraine
c'est ça la guerre pour l'anjou coûté
les turcs ont une attitude assez
généralement bizarre en ce moment il
négocie avec tout le monde surtout
sa pause s'impose véritablement
un problème ce qui est ce qui est clair
c'est que nous devons tous nous
mobiliser pour aider les ukrainiens
quand j'entends certains leaders
politiques d'hier en france qu'il faut
soutenir le cren moralement et ne pas
lui fournir d'armes je me dis que là on
est en pleine hypocrisie
c'est vraiment livré la victime à son
bourreau donc nous devons vous savez le
président theodore roosevelt qui était
un ancien président d'avoir la première
guerre mondiale
disait il faut avoir un gros bâton et
parler doucement c'est ce que nous
faisons
emmanuel macron ne
ne multiplie pas aller les rodomontades
politique contre poutine mais nous
apportons à l'ukraine nous les autres
européens les américains nous apportons
à l'ukraine des armes à ces sites est
très importante et c'est ça qu'il faut
l'ukraine vous savez le cren accrue ya
quelques semaines que la partie pouvait
être gagner comme ça c'est pas ainsi que
ça se passe nous voyons bien sur quoi se
replier sur quelle doctrine les russes
se sont pliés ils font la guerre comme
ils l'ont toujours fait à l'ancienne
comme on l'avait en quatorze fois je
disais l'artillerie l'artillerie
conquiert l'infanterie l'occupent
l'artillerie conc'air ça veut dire
l'artillerie détruites ou d'écrasement
l'écrasement et donc il faut il faut
bien prendre conscience que l'ukraine
est un pays plus faible que la russie
que l'ukraine a besoin d'être soutenu et
c'est là où se mesurent notre
détermination
j'enlève horloges des vingt-sept sont
réunis ce soir à bruxelles pour tenter
de se mettre d'accord sur un embargo sur
le pétrole russe
avec des réticences de la part de la
hongrie ce 6ème paquet de sanctions vous
avez l'impression que ça veut peut faire
payer moscou moi je n'ai jamais cru que
les sanctions en soi pouvait faire plier
qui que ce soit si elle n'était pas
accompagnée d'un effort effectivement
notamment d'un effort de soutien
militaire par exemple à l'ukraine mais
ça les sanctions doivent être faites
doivent être menées
elle pose un véritable problème à la
fédération de russie et non à des
difficultés pour quoi ton des
difficultés parce que monsieur monsieur
or ban est plutôt d'intelligence avec
monsieur poutine est ce que nous pouvons
nous les 400 millions quatre cent
quarante millions d'européens
accepté de nous voir dicter notre loi
par un pays un chef de gouvernement dix
millions d'habitants
elle en riant oui je parle de l'anglais
non il est tout à fait normal qu'un état
protège sa souveraineté il n'est pas
normal que c'est protection de
souveraineté se traduisent par la
paralysie tous les autres ultime
question la visite de catherine colonna
la nouvelle patronne de diplomatie
française à kiev avec ce soir volodymyr
zenasci elle était nécessaire il faut
lever quelques malentendus oui je crois
qu'il faut il ne faut pas comme je vous
le suggérez à l'instant il ne faut pas
laisser croire qu' il y aurait une
véritable division il ya en fait une
grande partie de des européens qui sont
des des enthousiastes les polonais qui
veulent la haye qui veulent qui estime
qu'on doit aller jusqu'au bout faire
piller et russe d'autres comme nous qui
sommes plus prudents plus attentifs au
rapport de force et mais en réalité nous
sommes d'accord les uns et les autres je
parle pas de langres il a mais les uns
et les autres ou sommes d'accord pour
apporter le maximum dead ou aux
ukrainiens et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
s'entendre merci à vous jean louis
bourlanges président de la commission
des affaires étrangères de l'assemblée
nationale et député modem des
hauts-de-seine merci à vous d'avoir été
l'invité de 18,50 france info merci jean
françois achilli